the united nations is warning of a
worsening humanitarian catastrophe in
ethiopia
on friday unicef said more than a
hundred thousand children
could face extreme starvation in the
next year as a result of major fighting
in that country's northern to gray
region
today u.s aid administrator samantha
power leaves for the embattled region
in hopes of easing what is now the
world's worst hunger crisis
in a decade the pictures out of to gray
are heart wrenching children in the
streets
families in disarray all under the
threat
of starvation food convoys have been
barred from accessing the region
it's been over a month since the last
one made its way through
our worst fears about the health and
well-being
of children in that conflicted region of
northern ethiopia are being confirmed
at a press conference on friday unicef
spokesperson marixe mercado said
aid workers need unfettered access to
prevent famine
and assaults like the one she described
on a young woman
she watched her grandmother get killed
she was raped by several men as she
watched her
nine-month-old baby being tossed around
by other
men the conflict pits ethiopia's central
government
led by prime minister abiye ahmed
against tigrayan forces to the north the
two sides had fought together
in a previous conflict with neighboring
eritrea
the peace deal brokered by ahmed won him
a nobel prize in 2019
and now he's embroiled in this this
catastrophe
how does that happen yeah unfortunately
i think prime minister abby
joins the list of nobel peace prize
winners who use all that good will
and squander it simon adams is the
executive director of the group
responsibility to protect there's no
good guys
in this conflict there are no real
heroes
in this except ordinary people who are
crushed
between these competing armed forces who
are displaced from their homes
by last november tensions between
ahmed's government
and tray turned violent it's estimated
that millions have since been displaced
a current humanitarian crisis not seen
in ethiopia
since the 1980s the head of usaid
uh samantha powers is heading over in
fact today
what can she do i think her visitors
sends a very powerful signal that
these atrocities can no longer be
ignored
adams says the 100 thousand children
that the u.n warrens are facing threat
of starvation
should be a hundred thousand reasons for
all sides
to end this conflict right now